on va découvrir maintenant ensemble les
très belles images de la sonde
européenne rosetta qui poursuit son
périple dans la galaxie elle vient de
croiser l'astéroïde lutetia qui se
trouve entre mars et jupiter le rendez
vous s'est déroulé exactement comme
prévu à 450 millions km de la terre
nicolas chateauneuf
c'est une rencontre à 450 millions de
kilomètres de la terre quelque part
entre mars et jupiter
voici l'astéroïde lutetia prise en photo
sous toutes les coutures
vu de près l'objet de 130 km de long
présente une surface tous remontés
criblé de cratères souvenir de la
jeunesse mouvementée du système solaire
l'auteur des clichés c'est la sonde
européenne rosetta habitué des
manoeuvres à haut risque au centre de
contrôle en allemagne les ingénieurs
étaient soulagés bonne nouvelle nous
sommes en train de recevoir les données
de la sonde spatiale
pour l'instant tout est parfait
rosetta est passée à 3200 kilomètres de
l'astéroïde les 400 clichés pris vont
aider les chercheurs à mieux comprendre
le destin de ce survivant des premiers
instants chaotique du système solaire
après cet exploit rosetta va entrer en
hibernation pour atteindre dans cinq ans
son but ultime
une comète sur laquelle elle déposera un
laboratoire miniature récoltant ainsi de
précieuses informations sur la formation
des planètes et notamment de la nôtre